Grüß Gott, ich bin Dr. Matt, ich bin zuständig für Sie, ich möchte heute mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerde sprechen,
aber so als brauche ich ein paar persönliche andaten, dann sprechen wir genau über Ihre Beschwerde.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Servus, mein Name ist Panda, Hans, Panda.
Panda und vor Hans.
Hans, können Sie Ihren Nachname buchstabieren?
Panda, P-A-N-D-A.
Und Vorname bitte?
Hans, H-A-N-S.
Herr Hans ja?
Nein, Herr Panda.
Herr Panda, Entschuldigung Herr Panda.
Panda, ich habe den buchstabiert.
Ja, ja, genau, Sie haben recht.
Wie alt ist Sie Herr Panda?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
61 Jahre alt, und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 1. März 1962 geboren, Herr Merth.
1. März 1962.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie Herr Panda?
Wie bitte?
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1.76 groß und wiege 85 Kilogramm.
1.76 und 85 Kilogramm schwer, ja?
Genau.
Sind Sie gegen COVID-19 geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ja, das ist gut.
Was können Sie tun, Herr Panda?
Herr Merth, ich habe seit 3 Tagen immer wieder Fieber.
Ich muss stark husten.
Das stört mich.
Fieber und Husten, ja?
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe das zu Hause gemessen.
Das war ungefähr 39.
Mit Ibuprofen konnte ich das gut senken, auf 37,5.
Aber ich habe immer wieder Fieber.
Das stört mich.
Ich kann nicht arbeiten, ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren.
Ich möchte die ganze Zeit schlafen.
Ich habe auch ganz Körperschmerzen.
Das husten stört mich sehr.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe das gestern gemessen.
Wie sagt Ihr Ihr Fieber aus?
Es war dick, braun.
Dick und braun, ja?
Ja.
Wann treten die Bescheiden auf?
Immer.
Ich bin ganz krank.
Deswegen bin ich heute in der Notaufnahme.
Ich habe etwas Angst, ehrlich gesagt.
Mein Kollege ist vor kurzem Lungkrebs gestorben.
Und ich habe nicht Lungkrebs.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorge.
Ich mache mir etwas Sorgen.
Ich glaube Ihnen, aber wir haben nur über Ihre Bescheidung gesprochen.
Wir werden alle an einem Lesbischen sprechen.
Über Ihre Bescheidung sprechen, dann entscheiden wir, ob Sie etwas haben.
Okay, machen Sie keine Sorge.
Und wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Wo?
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Nicht hier.
Okay.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur starke Husten.
Ich habe keine Altschmerzen.
Ich habe starke Husten.
Und mir geht es dreckig.
Haben Sie Hass oder Brust gemessen?
Nein, ich habe Brust gemessen.
Ich habe Brust gemessen.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Aber in Ruhe haben Sie keine Schmerzen.
Wenn ich eine habe, dann habe ich mich schon gemessen.
Ich habe kaum geschlafen die ganze Nacht.
Ich bin richtig müde.
Wir werden dieselbe Schmerzen bewegen, oder?
Ja, ich habe geschwitzt.
Ich habe Fieber gehabt.
Ich habe überall Schmerzen.
Ich habe ganz viel Ibuprofen geschlafen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Tabletten ich habe.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Ibuprofen?
Ja, die 400 habe ich genommen, die ich kaufen kann.
Ich muss wieder arbeiten.
Die Kunden warten, ich muss arbeiten.
Ich kann aber so nicht arbeiten.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Wir werden am besten für Sie machen.
Aber ich bitte Sie um ein bisschen Geduld.
Jetzt machen wir weiter.
Haben Sie beschleunigter Atem bemerkt?
Ich habe mich nicht bemerkt, weiß ich nicht.
Wie meinen Sie das denn?
Was heißt das?
Das heißt, Sie atmen so schner.
Als gewöhnlich.
Kann sein, weiß ich nicht.
Kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen?
Bekommen Sie schner?
Normalerweise atmen wir ungefähr 12 oder 15 Minuten.
Aber beschleunigt hat man über 20 Minuten.
Hab ich nicht gemessen, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, alles klar.
Bekommen Sie schmer Luft?
Ja, wenn ich liege, habe ich Schwere Luft.
Ich muss mal aufstehen, abwuchsen.
Muss Sie mal bemerken, weil ich laufen?
Nein, habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Wie viel Trappen können Sie beschleunigen?
Hab ich keine Probleme mit.
Hab ich auch nicht gezählt.
Okay.
Hab ich Schutters, Fros, Schwarz, Schurke?
Ja, die ganze Nacht habe ich geschwitzt.
Ich musste meine Hand wechseln.
Ich habe Zittern, Fieber, Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ich kann noch nichts mehr essen.
Ich habe gar keinen Hunger.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Haben Sie Investors seit Abodeuse gone?
Wie bitte?
Gleich, ich glaube.
Ich habe mich gebogen.
Letztes Mal habe ich mich vor vier, fünf Wochen gebogen.
Wie ist Ihr Studiengang?
Keine Probleme aktuell.
Aber ich esse hier nicht.
Deswegen habe ich wenig Studiengang.
Ich esse hier gar nichts.
Ich möchte wieder essen, aber es geht nicht.
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich glaube, Herr Panda, bei der Erkrankung
ist das normal.
Was haben Sie für eine Erkrankung?
Wir sind direkt schon.
Eigentlich haben wir nur über die aktuellen Bescheidung.
Aber ich bitte Sie, umgedrückt,
nach dem Anämenesgespräch aktuell,
nach dem Geschenkel,
und Köpferlike und außer dem
Ein paar Untersuchungen,
wenn ich Ihnen genau sagen kann,
was Sie haben.
Haben Sie noch andere Bescheidung?
Nein, ich bin richtig müde,
ich kann kaum auf den Beinen stehen.
Am liebsten würde ich mich wieder hinlegen.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut, Herr Panda.
Nun würde ich mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorerkrankung
sprechen.
Leiden Sie an Ihre Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme das für den Zucker ein
und für Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck?
Ja, schon lange, mehr als 10 Jahre jetzt.
Und Rücker, Sie haben mir gesagt,
Sie haben schon 3 Jahre gespielt.
Ja, seit 3 Jahren habe ich jetzt auch schon Zucker.
Ich mache mir auch Sorgen deswegen.
Alles klar.
Kennen Sie die Typ von der Stukalkrankanal?
Typ 1 oder Typ 2?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Er sagte nur, Sie haben Diabetes.
Dann gehe ich regelmäßig zur Kontrolle zu meinem Hausarzt.
Aber das ist gut.
Nehmen Sie dagegen,
Sie gehen regelmäßig,
Sie gehen mit dem Zucker,
Ja, bitte, das ist nicht gut.
Ja, ja, das stimmt.
Nehmen Sie dagegen,
Sie gehen mit dem Zucker,
Ich nehme für meinen Blutdruck,
ich nehme Ramipril ein.
Ramipril einmal.
Nehmen Sie morgen oder Abend?
Morgens, immer morgens,
immer zur gleichen Uhrzeit vor der Arbeit.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich glaube, das waren 10 Milligramm.
4 Milligramm.
Alles klar.
Nehmen Sie die Äigentöcher Medikamente,
die Blutdrucker kregen?
Ja, dann nehme ich Mattformin ein.
Mattformin?
Aber das nehme ich zweimal ein.
Nicht morgen und abends.
Ich glaube, das waren 500 gramm.
500, alles klar. Leiden Sie an irgendwelche noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, das sagen Sie ja.
Ich glaube schon, mein Ausatz hat Ihnen gesagt.
Alles klar. Nehmen Sie außer mit Formin und Gamipid noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ja jetzt, jetzt habe ich ganz viele Prophemen genommen, weil ich krank bin.
Ich bin normalerweise nicht so krank.
Ja, wir sind für Sie da.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Okay, Sie haben mit Formin 500 mg Gamipid und Ibuprofen bei Bedach.
Außer dieser Medikamente nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ich hatte mal einen Bruch in meinem Fuß, der wurde operiert vor 40 Jahren.
Was für ein Fuß?
Links.
Warum sind Sie operiert worden?
Unfall gehabt.
Hatten Sie eine irgendwelche Bruch?
Hab ich ja gesagt, mein Fuß war gebrochen.
Okay, ist die Kompetenz losverläufe?
Ja, aber alles gut. Vor 40 Jahren, ne? Das ist schon lange her.
Das war ich 20 Jahre alt.
Alles klar.
Sind Sie aussender am Grund operiert worden?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Okay, wurden Ihnen aussender am Grundstationär aufgenommen?
Wie bitte?
Wurden Ihnen aussender am Grundstationär aufgenommen?
Hab ich nicht verstanden.
Ja, waren Sie schon im Krankenhaus?
Jetzt heute?
Nein, früher, mein ich.
Ich bin schon mal stationär aufgenommen worden.
Nein, ich bin selten krank am Erd.
Okay, das ist gut, aber.
Sind bei Ihnen Algin bekannt?
Nein.
Perfekt tragen Sie Mikro- und Reideprodukte zum Beispiel, Brot, Obst oder Gemüse?
Ich kann alles essen, nicht erst sogar zu viel.
Okay, das ist gut.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Panda?
Ja, ich rauche.
Was rauchen Sie?
Zigaretten.
Malboro.
Halbbeschachter, oder?
Ah, malboro, ah, Schuldigmann.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Ja, eine Packung, eine Packung am Tag.
Mit einer Packung meinen Sie 20 Zigaretten, ja?
Ja, ungefähr.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Auch schon lange, als ich 20 war, 19 so um den Dreh, lange her.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Am Wochenende.
Am Wochenende, was trinken Sie?
Ja, Bier, generell Bier.
Wenn Sie Flasche oder Gläser?
Ja, kommt drauf an, Flasche, Glas, Beides kommt auf die Situation,
aber meistens eine Flasche oder mehrere Flaschen am Wochenende.
Alles klar.
Okay, Routine-mäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen haben?
Ob ich Kontakt, ob ich selber Drogen nehme?
Ja, ja.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Nein. Keine Drogen.
Ich bin kein Junkie.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschiedet.
Geschiedet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn, ja.
Hab ich aber keinen Kontakt zu.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, zuletzt war er gesund.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Herr Panda?
Ich bin Taxifahrer, ich bin Taxunternehmer.
Deswegen muss er wieder arbeiten, und es läuft der Laden nicht.
Ich glaube, ja.
Aber gesundheit ist auch sehr wichtig.
Deswegen muss ich schnell gesund werden und weiterarbeiten.
Ja, machen Sie keine Sorgen, wir werden am besten für Sie.
Okay.
Wir haben genug Erfahrung über die Erfährung.
Ja, deswegen brauche ich gute Medikamente, damit ich schnell wieder arbeiten kann.
Ja.
Okay, machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Sind Sie stressausgesetzt?
Taxifahrer immer.
Immer stress.
Träben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich habe keine Zeit für Sport, ich muss arbeiten.
Okay.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Familiengeschichte.
Ich habe keine Familiengeschichte, ich bin geschiedet.
Ich meine Ihr Vater oder Ihrer Mutter,
gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Vorarl- krankungen?
Ja, meine Eltern sind beide gestorben.
Ich habe keine Eltern, die sind gestorben.
Ja, das ist alles gut.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Meine Mutter war einfach alt, sie ist über 90 Jahre alt,
da war sie bis zum gestorben.
Aber gibt es bestimmte Grund?
Die war alt, ne? Die war 90 Jahre alt.
Okay, weil sie wegen Alter war, die war am Heim,
die war morgens aufgewacht, oder nicht aufgewacht.
Sie ist in der Nacht gestorben.
Okay, klar.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Wir sehen uns auf und zu.
Sie ist gesund anscheinend, hat, glaube ich, auch Zucker.
Okay.
Das war meine Frage Herr Pfand,
haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Ich habe ja gesprochen, ganz lange.
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Eigentlich ein Medikament, oder ist es etwas Schlimmes?
Das Krebs?
Eigentlich kann ich nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Wie meine ich das?
Ich möchte auch ein paar Unterseuchungen.
Sie haben doch gerade gesagt,
nach dem Gespräch können Sie mir sagen, was ich habe.
Ja, genau, Sie haben recht.
Ich möchte auch körperlich untersuchen,
dann rundgen veranlassen.
Dann kann ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber das sieht...
Also Sie untersuchen mich, dann machen wir Röntgen, ja?
Ja, ja, so als würde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich rundgen Torax veranlassen.
Muss man doch Blut abnehmen oder so?
Ja, ja, genau.
Ich würde auch Blut abnehmen.
Können Sie dann da sehen, ob ich etwas Schlimmes habe?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe Verdacht auf eine Pneumonie
oder eine Entschuldigung.
Das ist, das ist ein Entschündigeprozess.
Deswegen, ich würde auch Blut abnehmen.
Deswegen sind diese Erkrankungen gut behandelt.
Wir werden, wenn ich diese Erkrankung genau diagnostiere,
werde ich ein paar Medikamente verschreiben.
Mit Hilfe dieser Medikamente können Sie gut heilen.
Kann ich dann wieder nach Hause oder muss ich hier bleiben?
Ja, eigentlich müssen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich würde körperlich untersuchen, auch Blut abnehmen.
Und gefahren zwei oder drei Stunden müssen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Oder aber lange.
Ja, leider.
Ja, nehmen Sie jetzt Blut ab oder was machen Sie jetzt?
Soll ich jetzt hier warten?
Ja, ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen jetzt.
Okay, dann soll ich mich ausziehen?
Ja, ja, das ist besser.
Ich würde Sie abhören auch.
Ja, dann machen Sie mal.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, ich kann vielleicht eine atmen.
Wenn ich liege.
Wenn Sie beschwerden, gibt es...
Wie bitte?
Ja, in letzter Zeit haben Sie sich beschwerden.
Nee, gar nicht.
Ich bin nie krank, das erste Mal kaputt, fertig.
Also mir geht es nicht gut.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland bleiben?
Ich war in Holland.
Ich denke, das ist was.
Können wir erst als ich beanfangen?
Nur Allah.
Ja, ja, ja.
Grüß Gott, Herr Oberatz.
Wir haben einen neuen Patienten, nämlich Hans Panda.
Ich würde über ihn berichten. Darf ich?
Ja, Servus, gerne können Sie machen.
Herr Panda ist 61 Jahre alt, 1,76 m groß,
85 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen,
bestehlter Husten mit purulantem Auswurf,
so wie FIBA bis zu 39,
Grazie als Hüso.
Er hat das FIBA anders gemessen.
Als begleitende Symptome,
klackte er über Konzentrationen,
Fatigue, Schmerzen bei der Inspiration und Orthopneas.
Er hat das FIBA,
die er gegen diese Bescheidung,
400 mg eingrenommen hat.
Aber das hilft ihn nicht.
Die vegetative Anamnese
gab ihn somit in Appetenz
und Hyperhydrosa.
Alle Vorerkrankungen sind bei ihm die folgenden Bekannte.
Seit 3 Jahren Diabetes Magnetus.
Seit 4 Jahren Altheriale Hypertony.
Mit 20 Jahren
hat er eine Fuß gebrochen.
Er hat die operative Behandlung erledigt.
Er hat eine Fußgebrochen.
Er hat eine ähnliche Anzahl.
Er hat eine Fußbremse pro Tag.
und Unverträglichkeiten sind bei ihm unbekannt. Herr Panda auch seit dem 20. Lebensjahr 20
Zigaretten täglich. Außerdem trinkt er ein bis zwei Flasche anmohrenende.
Er ist ein Drohkonsumverleid. Herr Panda ist geschieden und hat einen Sohn.
Er ist Taxifahrer von Beruf. Er leidet unter Viehschädres.
Der Vater des Patienten ist an einer Apopylex verstorben. Die Mutter des Patienten ist wegen einer Alters verstorben.
Das wäre oft kundesalters verstorben.
Ja Altersgurt, ja Altersgurt verstorben.
Warum ist es gestorben?
Der Patient weiß nicht, warum er verstorben ist.
Die Anamnestische Angaben sind am erster auf einer neuen Menü hin.
Differenzierendurch müsste ich kommen und auch Covid-19 und akute Fonsilitis im Betrag.
Was ist das?
Hat er den Altsschmerzen?
Nein, sie hat keinen Verstorben.
Unwahrscheinlich, dass er eine Fonsilitis hat.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Sie glauben, dass er eine Lungenentzündung hat?
Warum glauben Sie das?
Die Fibar ist bis zu 39 und die Husten mit Purulantenauswahl.
Allgemeine Fatigue.
Und Schmerzen bei der Inspiration.
Sprechen für Pneumoni.
Könnte sein, dass er auch eine COPD hat?
Ja, das kann eine Absorbation von COPD sein.
Aber das ist nicht möglich, da der Patient nur seit 3 Tagen beschwerden hat.
Und fragen nach, wo die COPD von Erkrankungen wurde.
Vielleicht weiß er das nicht, ob er eine COPD hat.
Aber wenn er schon seit 40 Jahren raucht, dann hätte mit sich eine COPD.
Also mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit hat er eine COPD.
Aber er weiß es nicht und der Aussatz hat das auch nicht kontrolliert.
Aber es kann natürlich eine exerzervierte COPD sein.
Erst Diagnose könnte sein.
Aber Sie haben schon recht, dass, was Sie beschreiben,
deutlich am meisten auf eine Lungenentzündung hin.
Wie bestätigen Sie diese Diagnose, Herr Merz?
Ja, so als würde ich Vitalparameter und überprüfen,
dann würde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Aber bei diesem Patient gibt es keine Siagnose.
Außerdem, beim Abhören kann ich eine Auskultation hören.
Und außerdem verminderte Atemgeräusche.
Beim Abhören kann ich eine Vocalfremitus überprüfen.
Wir geben ein paar Einweisungen zum Beispiel 99 sagen.
Auf dieser Weise können wir eine Epinomene erkennen oder ausschließen.
Außerdem würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Bei Blut erwarte ich erhöhte Entzündungsparameter
und habe eine Blutgasanalyse gemacht.
Auf dieser Weise können wir eine mögliche Sauerstoffmangel erkennen.
Wie nennt man das Sauerstoffmangel?
Ja, mithilfe von BGA.
Wie nennt man das einen Sauerstoffmangel?
Hypoksy.
Ja, infrabriert, Hypoksy nennt.
Hypoksemi, oder Hypoksy.
Und außerdem würde ich Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Beim Röntgen-Torax können wir eine Milchglas...
Das würden Sie erst sehen, wenn er eine Covid-19 hat,
aber bei einer Lungenentzündung würden Sie eine Verschattung,
einen Infiltrat, ein Papier,
ein Infiltrat, das zum Beispiel sehen,
eine vermerrte Zeichnungsvermehrung,
oder ein gelbter Milchglasartiger.
Verschattung.
Okay, also glauben, dass seine Lungenentzündung hat.
Das klingt ganz gut, ich denke, Sie haben recht,
dass seine Lungenentzündung hat.
Was spricht gegen, dass eine schwerwiegende Lungenentzündung hat?
Was spricht der Regel?
Ja, die E-Beshware treten plöstig auf, das schippte ich dagegen.
Und FIBA bis zu 39°,
sprich ich dagegen auch.
Okay, und der Patient hat keine Gewichtsverlust,
der hat, im Prinzip ist das ganz okay.
Gut, wovon machen Sie das jetzt abhängig,
ob der Patient stationär bleibt,
oder ob Sie ihn nach Hause lassen?
Ja, je nach Körp 65,
entscheiden wir stationär aufnehmen.
Können Sie mir den CRB65-Score erklären?
Ja.
C bedeutet Konfusion,
U bedeutet Uremie,
R bedeutet Respe,
Atemfrekanz, Resperatorer,
und B bedeutet Blutdruck,
Atelereplatone,
und 65 bedeutet Alter von Patient.
Und dieses Blutdruck, wie nett sich das ist,
ist das stationierend richtig hoch, wovon dann geht es ab?
Ja,
von über 140 Sprächen,
entsprechen wir eine Atelierhypertonie.
Richtig, aber da haben Sie recht,
aber ich möchte nicht wissen,
was eine Atelierhypertonie ist,
sondern, was der Blutdruck bei diesem CRB65
bedeutet,
das gibt Ihnen für eine Aussage,
darf er nicht zu hoch sein,
oder darf er nicht zu niedrig sein?
Meiner Meinung nach,
es soll es niedrig sein,
Atelierhypertonie.
Hab ich nicht verstanden.
Jetzt haben Sie den Patienten,
der Patient hat einen Druck von 100 zu 70.
Ist das gut oder schlecht im Rahmen
der Atelierhypertonie?
Das ist schlecht.
Ja,
die Atelierhypertonie
sagt uns ein schlechtes Problem.
Ja,
die Atelierhypertonie,
Hypertonie,
OK, habe ich falsch verstanden.
OK, man sagt immer,
normalerweise, ich mache das mal kurz,
dass wenn der Blutdruck,
der süßtolische Blutdruck unter 90 ist,
bzw. der diastolische Blutdruck unter 60 ist,
ist das eine schlechte Prognose ungefähr.
Also das hat nichts mit erhöhtem Blutdruck,
sondern mit niedrigem Blutdruck.
Ja,
Sie haben echt, ja.
Und was ist mit der Atemfrequenz?
Atemfrequenz,
die Atemfrequenz,
über von 20.
Atmet pro Minute.
Also hier über 20,
dann heißt das,
ist das nicht gut oder,
oder ist das OK 20?
Das ist ja,
über von 20.
Über 30 sagt man,
über 30,
120, 30,
so eine Drehe.
Das wäre wichtig zu wissen,
das müssen Sie wissen.
Dieser Score,
dieser CURB 65,
den müssen Sie sofort bestimmen.
Damit Sie erkennen können,
ob das eine schwerwiegende Erkrankung ist,
ob man den Patienten stationär behalten muss,
oder ob man diesen Patienten außerhalb des Krankenhaus,
also ambulant führen kann
und ihn wieder zum Haushalt schicken kann.
So, jetzt haben Sie diesen Patienten untersucht.
Wir haben gesehen,
er hat eine Lungenentzündung,
er hat ein Infiltrat in linken Lungenflügel,
unterlappend links,
eine unterlappende Prämonie
und der Blutdruck ist 100,
zu 70 sage ich mal.
Der Patient ist 61 Jahre alt.
Was machen Sie?
Schicken Sie den nach Hause
und wie behandeln Sie den jetzt?
Eigentlich hat der Patient
keine Tatjubel mehr.
Der Alter von Patient 61 Jahre alt.
Je nach dieser Score
können wir
dieser Patient,
dieser Patient ambulant
verhandeln.
Ja, frage ich jetzt,
ambulant stationär,
was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Eigentlich hat der Patient
keine Tatjubel mehr
und ich frage jetzt, ambulant stationär,
was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Ja, ambulant,
wir können einfach eine Rezept schreiben.
Was schreiben wir auch?
Je nach erregiger
können wir eine Rezept
verschreiben.
Haben Sie den Erreger?
Aber davor
sollen wir eine
Ausrufkultur machen.
Wie lange dauert das?
Ja, das dauert lange.
Heute Samstag?
Ja.
Was machen wir?
Soll wir sagen, Sie müssen warten,
bis auf die Blutkultur
oder bis auf die Skutumkultur,
was machen wir mit den Patienten?
Nehmen wir den auf,
dann werden wir den nicht auf.
Wir verschreiben
eine
Weitspektur
um Antibiotikum.
Was können Sie geben?
Zum Beispiel
Amoxicin können wir verschreiben.
Ja.
Ausserdem
Makrolit
Kloridromissen
können wir auch verschreiben.
Was verschreiben Sie, sagen Sie mal?
Was geben Sie den Patienten?
Ausserdem
verschreiben ich Antibiotikum.
Hält für das oder das?
Oder geben Sie beides?
Antibiotikum ist genug.
Was geben Sie?
Ich verschreibe Makrolit.
Okay.
Ist okay, gut.
Ausserdem
verschreibe ich
eine Antibiotikum,
eine Anergetik.
Antibiotikum hat er schon zu Hause,
eben, wofäl, hat er schon genug?
Ja, ich muss nachfragen,
ob der Patient
genug überprofen hat.
Noch 50 Stück zu Hause.
Ja, das ist immer klar.
Okay, und
sagen Sie eben, Sie müssten die Antibiotika
nehmen und dann ist alles gut?
Oder empfehlen Sie eben noch
etwas anderes?
Ja, ja.
Ich empfehle auch
Körperberichtschonung,
Betrucher,
viel Wasser
sofort Wasser
Wasser zu konsumieren.
Ausserdem
wird empfehlen
der Patient
eine
Kontrolle nach
spätersten, zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen, okay.
Spätersten, ja.
Wo, im Krankenhaus, oder wo?
Je nach
der Beschwerden empfehlen
wir
die
eine Hausarzt.
Ja,
der Patient
man empfiehlt normalerweise
Folgendes.
Man sagt dem Patient, okay,
Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung, Sie bekommen
eine Antibiotikum von uns, Sie können
jetzt für eine Hause gehen, körperliche
Schonung, bitte
nach fünf Tagen bis eine Woche
Kontrolle beim Hausarzt,
beziehungsweise, wenn es schlimmer werden sollte,
wenn es sich nicht besser geht unter der
Therapie, bitte wieder zurück
zu uns, Wiedervorstellungen bei uns
im Krankenhaus.
Weil Sie entlasten den Patienten
und Sie haben im Prinzip jetzt die Verantwortung
für ihn, solange er sich nicht
beim Hausarzt vorstellt.
Deswegen ist es immer gut
zu schreiben in den Arztbrief oder den Patient
zu sagen, wenn es nicht schlechter geht,
bitte kommen Sie wieder, also
eine Wiedervorstellung empfehlen,
ist ganz wichtig, ja.
Damit der Patient weiß, okay, ich soll wieder zurück
ins Krankenhaus, wenn es mir nicht gut geht.
Es kann sein, dass er eine atypische Prämonie
hat, dass das Antibiotikum nicht anschlägt
oder dass er jetzt doch ein Pluragus
entwickelt hat
oder ein Selbstes entwickelt, übermorgen
wissen Sie nicht, deswegen soll er
wieder ins Krankenhaus, ne?
Ja.
Ganz wichtig, das zu erwähnen, ja?
Ja, sehr gut, haben Sie gut gemacht.
Was für?
Dann können Sie den Patienten jetzt wieder
nach Hause schicken.
Herr Murat,
das ist ein loberprinum.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein loberprinum.
Ja, eine Pluramonie ist sehr wichtig, ne?
Pluramonie ist ein atypisches oder typisches?
Nein, das ist eine Pluramonie.
Was für?
Also, man muss das eigentlich nicht
laut dem CURB 65 Score
muss man nicht machen.
Es kommt darauf an, klinisch wie er ist,
weil er seine Tachik knört,
sehr schnell
eratmet, aber er hat wahrscheinlich
eine ambulanzerworbene Pneumonie.
Keine
Nosekomiale Pneumonie, das heißt,
die Erreger sind wahrscheinlich mit unseren
Antibiotika gut behandelbar, ne?
Die letzte Empfehlung, soweit ich weiß,
ist sogar
bei diesen Patienten
glaube ich
amoxizidiklavulansäure plus
Makrolit, ne?
Also doppelte Antibiotika eventuell,
kommt dabei immer auf die Klinik des Patienten an.
Okay.
Also eine ambulante
ambulanzerworbene Pneumonie.
Also eine CAP, CAB
Community Acroponemonie.